صوره واحده فقط صدرت من هنا في امريكا
وتحولت الى زلزال في مصر فما القصه
[موسيقى]
ببشره سمراء
ملصق دعائي لسلسله وثائقيه ستعرضها منصه
نتفليكس في العاشر من مايو السلسله تروي
سيره اخر ملكات مصر الفرعونيه ومنتجه
العمل ليست الا جيده
الذي دافع عنها خلال حفل الاوسكار في
العام الماضي
صفع حينها مقدم الحفل كروس روك بسبب نكته
سمجه عن شعر جيده لكن كيلوباترا السمراء
ويعلي المفارقه تعيد جيد سميث الى الاضواء
وعنوان هذه المفارقه حركه
فكريه تعتقد ان مصر القديمه حكمها
الافارقه ذو البشره السمراء والفراعنه
قدموا من قلب افريقيا ليصبحوا فراعنه مصر
هذه الفكره تغضب المصريين كثيرا فكيف تبدو
صوره من ارض كيلوباترا صوره كليوباترا
السمراء تحولت ازمه وعرائضه مع عشرات الاف
الطواقيع والمطلب واحد اوقفوا عرض السلسله
ولكن هل هناك شيء من العنصريه في هذا
الغضب المصري
المعترضون لديهم رساله واضحه ليست هناك
مشكله ان تكون الملكه سمراء المشكله ان
يكون ذلك تزييفا للتاريخ
مرفوضون عموما هنا في مصر تذكروا
كليوباترا مصريه يونانيه وهي اخر من حكم
مصر القديمه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات